WIUTIN TO A MEMORIAL OE
UNKNOWSOLDIER.
MATTW ON IN LOND
UKRAINED C THAT
LONG-AWAITOUE
E NOT JUSTF TH
E THAN0 >> YEAH.
DO, THERRERYAND THHEAD.
EROFFEE OT QUITE UNDERUTS EDKEL.
ARMID OF COURSE
ONDENTS.
A EUROOUPA
ADVANCED WEAPONRY IOARAIFRMANYE
AND FROM FRANCE.
ORTING DAILY ADVANCE
IN THE CITY OFUT.
USSIANPA CRUMBLING.
>> Translator: NOW THE ALLEGATI,
OFFERED UKRAINE INTELLIGENCE ON
RUSSIAN MILITARY POSIOITW ITS TE
PRIGOZHIN HAS VEHEMENTLY DENIED
ENCCG COAD IN F TRYING TO
DISMISSED ANY
TAMY
A UKRAINIAN OFFICIAL TELLING CNN
THAT IN HAD BEEN NG WITHOUT THE
BUT THESE ARE GHT TIMES FOIN.
LUKASHEN OG , ALEXR
LOUN E IN MOSCOW LAST WEEK, IS
WREATH-LAYING CEREMONY AT TANSI
W  TO BE O AL
INSPECTING AIR DEFENSES, BUT
RUMORSD ABOUT THE OFS AGG
MEANWHILE, A UKRAINIAN OFFICIAL
CALLING P ZELENSKYY'S
EUROPEAN TOUR A HUGETHIS LATT L
BRITISH PRIME MINISTER AT HIS
COUNTRY RESIDENCE WHERE ATTACK
WERE PLEDG.AIRSE SYSTEMS
>> I LK FORWARD TO US
E N
>> THANK YOU VERU SUPPORTED ALR
.
>> WSSILES AEA
UKS NO
FOREONNG
LONG-RANGE
THERE WAS RO O
GAME-CHANGING  JETOM ANYOP
NEILL, A UKRAINIIAL , IN TE, THG
PP S D
N OFS HOLDING UP ARLY FROM THE
STATES
USON
UKRAINIAN WAR EF, S
STILL THE U.S. THAT'S TH
BIGGESMO MILITBACKER FOR THE>> E
ERAL BEN HODGES,
THE FORMERTHY EUROPE.RAL HODGES
AI SCE REEAY OF THIS WAR FOUR
RUSSIAN AIRCRAFT DOWNED OVER
RUSSIAN TERRITORY THIS WEEKEND.
AT THIS
T FOUR AIRCRAFT
IN WOULD CERD
SHOCK WAVES THROUG
FORCES,T LIKEWOD USSIAN
I'M TETHIS
HAED
EET UKRAINE MAY HAVE E TOE
CAPABILIN THERE STILT
ENTIONFIRMED HOW IHAPPENED.
BUT IFY'THAT,
THAT WOULD REAY DEMONSTRATE A
SOPHISTICATION TH HE RUSSI
BUT IT'S IMPORTANTT RUSSIA
BEHAVE T L
UKRAINIAN
ANSO
TO CONTINU TAK WIT
TH
>> ANDBV TIAN TERROR
HAPPENED.
AMSSULLIVAN, PUTIN'S
MOST LOYALTTHEW REPORTIN PLUKAS.
AI
UNITS WEREIGH ALERT TH
HE IS THERE EVERY STEP OF THE Y
BELA R
CRUCIAL.AND HES K DIOR
BANDAGE ON HIS
LONGER IN POWER,
T DO TO PUTIN,
AM
>>T'LEFO
ENKOT LUKAKO
S RULELARUSIANHA
AUTHORITARIAN HAND FOR ALMOST 30
YEARS.
PUTIN'S WAR AGAINST E FOREIGLEA
P WITH MOREN  ELSE.
I THINK HEING LIMES SINCE
THE
, HE IS MOST IMPORTANT
AL.>> MOST HE EA SCOW, IT APPEAE
AND HE IS PUN'T ALLY.
ACTUALLY GIVE PUSOG
THATE BLY AN
TO EN
UKRAIN
>> WELL, I SEE IT ASN
UNITY INOR AN EXCUSE TGET OUT
OF THIS WA LOSING UKRAINE.
IS A IT ISTH IN ORDER
THEY MIGHT HAV
CRUSHED IN UKRALLY
WITH, YOU COULD AL
O WHERE BERUE TH.
COURSE,ON.
EA WOULD
HAPP IS THAT THE PEOPLE OF
BELARUS WOULD SEE THE
RTTO OFF
TH OION
SERVI A 17-YEARN ID ARE OITN LS
PRESIDENT SENTENCE,  IGE O IN S
FROM THAUNMAHUSETTATHANNELLED UO
INFORMIAN TROO
THKID THAT HE
COULD THEN TOV BAKHMUT
PUTIN, WELL, IT CERTAINLY,E LEFH
BU
PUT IN CHARG
ISA MILITARY E WAGNER GROUPS S .
RELIEDN PEOPLE, HE'S
NG NOWH
PRIGOZHIN POSSIBLY DOING THI SAS
LIKE THE RUSSI
FEE CHIEF OF THE
GENEL HEIRD S.
EN YOU LOOK AT THE
STATE OF THE RN , YOU COME ON T
HE
HEM THE THANKI
SUG NISTER F
THOSE SHADOWISMI
FROM THE UEM ME
DISTAN GETTING EXTREMELY
SI FROM TH
RE ONOT?
WRE LOOKING AT THBEGINNING OF R
SHIFT.
THIS DIDN' BACCIDENT.Y NEY ALL
SUPPRAINE HAVE BEEN
WORKINVERY HARD STFE
BUT IT REALLY WATHN HAT HAVE ME
UKRAINIAKHD RUSSIAN FORCESO
BLEED THEMSELF THERE.
PUTL THE OTHER GOOD NEW
SENSE THATE CLOSE TO UKRAINE AC.
I THTHNTEROFFENSIVE,ERE UKIA
READY, NUMBER TWO, HAVE DEGRAD
ANEE, ISGROUND?